Firstly,
I wanted to just do what I forgot to show you.
I don't know how exciting this is.
Mine,
this is a ticker tape.
Um,
and uh,
they weren't brown.
This tape is about a half century old.
Uh,
it came from the attic of the New York Stock Exchange.
when I was at a conference there a year ago,
I mentioned to,
I'm the vice president there that I told my class about ticker tape machines and
they'd never heard of them,
didn't know what they were.
Let's see.
Some of them had,
so he sent me this,
this is never used.
Uh,
but normally it would go into a machine and it would print out stock prices at
trades.
Uh,
but then I,
I was,
I was giving a talk yesterday at the New York stock.
I met him again and I said,
thank you for this.
My class was happy to see him.
And he said,
well,
I could've given you a whole ticker tape machine.
And he said,
well,
he said,
the attic at the New York Stock Exchange,
it was filled with them,
but they finally threw them out.
So it's too late.
Um,
but I think it is,
this is evidence that,
uh,
that,
information technology really has dominated stock prices.
We didn't really have active stock markets before the electronic age.
It does an interesting thing to think about because the ticker tape machine was
invented by Edison in 1867 and in 1867,
there were hardly any,
there were stock markets,
but they were very small.
It was really the electronic communications that made it what it is.
Um,
and uh,
it's exciting to think about the future and where electronic communications is
going to take markets,
uh,
going forward.
Uh,
so I wanted to,
uh,
continue today about a futures markets.
Uh,
let me just step back and think what is a futures market.
And today I'm going to talk about how it has expanded to cover,
uh,
lots of other things,
notably financial,
financial instruments,
but let's just think what is a futures market.
And the,
um,
uh,
if you read Holbrook working,
who's on your reading list,
uh,
and his old half century old paper back in these days and he was writing,
um,
he says that the name futures is a bit misleading because that suggests that
it's talking about the future rather than today.
But if you listen to the news about any commodity price,
uh,
it's always talking about futures.
Pr.
They don't talk about the price today.
Uh,
and,
uh,
the futures price is the interesting and the point that we're working made.
It's not so much that it's in the future is that it's well defined and
standardized.
Uh,
it's on,
uh,
so for agricultural futures,
it's true that the contract doesn't mature for a month or so.
But,
uh,
as working points out,
you know,
any contract for delivery of something has some term they don't deliver it
instantly.
And working says there are times when the so-called spot price is actually
further in the future,
then the future is priced.
Uh,
and so if you look at the way things are traded for,
I'm going to be talking a lot about oil,
but let me just talk generally about oil.
What is the price of oil and how does anybody know what it is?
If you go to people who buy and sell oil,
they will tell you,
well,
we don't just sell oil.
You know,
we don't just have it ready to go.
Uh,
almost all of the oil is sold in longterm contract.
So an oil company will sell a contract to deliver regularly to some,
uh,
refinery,
oil.
They will have these tankers appear and we sign out,
you know,
a five year contract or whatever.
Uh,
and it has all kinds of terms.
If you read the contract,
it'd be 50 pages long and it would specify all kinds of what we'll do if we
don't deliver it.
What happens if we can't deliver the grade we promised?
Um,
and you know,
lots of uncertainties or just define.
So who knows what the price of oil is when it's being part of a longterm
contract.
So that's why you need a futures market in the futures market is,
is the market,
uh,
that's free of it has a standardized contract.
And so we know exactly what the price means.
And,
and attention focuses on the futures market because the trade there is,
um,
everybody understands it.
Everyone knows exactly what's being traded in the minute to minute changes
reflect something and they reflect something real,
namely that change in the market,
not any change in what's being delivered.
So,
uh,
so anyway,
it used to be that the only futures markets were for commodities for things
typically that it was thought that futures markets are good to have for things
that are not standardized,
that are difficult to define.
So we want rice futures and we want wheat futures because there's so many
different kinds of rice in different areas and different.
And so,
uh,
we want to have a standardized price.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
there were no financial futures until the 1970s.
And people,
uh,
felt back then that we don't need a futures contracts because,
there's a standardization of,
of shares.
Every share,
uh,
in a given company is exactly identical,
right?
When you say,
I'd like to buy a hundred shares of a company,
a,
you're not going to ask the broker,
well,
which shares did I get?
And can I look at them in the broker would say in disbelief,
look,
you've got shares,
they're all absolutely identical.
Uh,
and so you might think there's no need for a futures,
uh,
because it's,
prices are already standardized in the cash market.
Moreover,
the prices that you see traded on the stock exchange floor,
you know exactly when the trade took place so they're not future traded.
So why did we get futures markets?
Um,
well let me come back to that.
Let me just first,
why did we get stock futures markets?
The,
let me come back to that and talk about just that.
Let's be clear what,
what they are a stock index.
Futures markets came in around 1980.
Uh,
and,
uh,
one of the very first was the standard and poor 500 stock index futures market
traded at the Chicago Mercantile Exchange.
Uh,
it,
it was a radical innovation when it came in,
uh,
because people thought,
what's the point?
You know,
I can see farmers delivering their corn or their oats or whatever,
but stocks,
what's the point?
Well,
it turned out to be absolutely right because,
uh,
the CME was absolutely right to create this market because within a few years
there was more trade on the futures market than there was on the stock market
itself.
So let's be clear what they created.
And this is the terms of the contract as it is today.
The S and p 500 is an index of stock prices produced by standard and Poor's
corporation.
Uh,
and it's,
they take the prices of 500 stocks and they form a weighted average.
It's an arithmetic average,
uh,
with the weights correspond to the amounts outstanding of the various stock.
So it's evaluated index.
It's just a number published by the,
uh,
American soccer.
My Standard and poor,
I'm sorry.
Uh,
and all it is at,
uh,
just as with,
um,
agricultural futures.
I don't know how clear I was about this yesterday.
If you,
maybe I didn't say this.
Let me say anything that applies both to agricultural futures and financial
futures.
If you want to trade in the futures market,
you have to put up margin.
Okay.
Uh,
and there's a margin requirement for each contract.
That margin is there to eliminate counterparty risk with other contracts.
When you sign a contract with another person,
uh,
you have to worry whether that person will come through.
But with the exchange it's uh,
that counterparty risk is eliminated.
And the way the exchange eliminates it is it takes the other side itself of
every contract.
So it stands between you and the counterparty and it protects itself by
demanding margin.
So you a have to upfront put up margin for any futures contract.
And the margin is settled daily.
Every day they look at your margin account and they adjusted.
Okay.
So if,
uh,
let me go back to wheat futures because that's the simpler,
I don't think I really explained this well.
If you buy,
when we say buy wheat futures,
what does that mean?
That means it's the word buy or sell has a different meaning in futures markets.
When you buy wheat futures or for that matter s and p 500 futures,
it means that you put up margin,
you did not pay the price for the contract.
You only paid margin,
which might be 5% or less than the price.
Okay,
so if it's a,
uh,
if you're buying wheat futures,
what are you doing?
You're putting up margin and standing ready to see your margin account credited
or debited depending on the change in the futures price from day to day.
So if the price of wheat in the futures market goes up and you bought futures,
they will increase your margin account by the amount that it went up.
And if the price of wheat goes down,
they will decrease your margin account balance by that amount.
How do they get the money?
Well,
that's because for every buyer there's a seller in the futures market.
So somebody else sold futures.
Both of you put up margin.
If you are buying,
you put up margin,
if you are selling,
he put up margin.
And so the result is that they have a place to get the money.
So if the price goes up and you bought your margin account will go up the
exchange.
We'll get the money by taking it from the margin account of the guy who sold and
they've always fixed it so that the number of buyers always equals the number of
sellers.
Okay.
So you see how the exchange can't lose and you can't lose.
This is a guaranteed thing.
Um,
the only problem is that what if a margin account runs dry?
Okay.
So,
uh,
both buyer and seller have put up margin and then the price,
let's say the price drops a lot,
the futures price drops a lot.
Then that means that the,
uh,
the,
the buyer's margin account is wiped out.
What'll happen then is that the future's commission merchant will go to the
person who bought the futures and say,
do you want to post more margin or do you want me to close you out?
Okay.
Uh,
and,
uh,
that person has a decision to make a,
and if he or she puts up more margin,
then that replenishes the margin account and the person can keep trading.
That's,
that's how the exchanges eliminate counterparty risk by daily resettlement of
the contracts.
All right,
so it's an invention actually it goes back to Japan,
although it's slightly different in form.
It's an invention that eliminates any risk of the counterparty not performing,
so that risk doesn't affect price.
So it's the same,
I you clear on that now how the margin account work,
you might not enjoy this,
this,
uh,
it depends on how,
how much of a gambling instinct you have or how much fun is it?
If you buy or sell futures,
you can expect a phone call from your broker as sooner or later.
Well,
not necessarily,
unless you have incredibly good luck.
Um,
so,
uh,
Hillary Clinton,
when she invested in the futures market,
uh,
she had incredibly good luck.
You know this story,
uh,
when her husband Bill Clinton was governor,
she,
um,
got a call from a friend recommended to her very good broker who knew how to
trade in and commodity futures.
And so she put up something like $1,000,
uh,
of her own money.
Uh,
and then the,
uh,
the broker kept calling her and asking her what she wanted to do.
Uh,
and you know,
she just never lost anything.
She turned it into $100,000,
uh,
within a year.
Uh,
and then she stopped.
And we don't know why I'm not,
I'm not anti Hillary Clinton.
This is just a futures market story.
I liked her a lot.
But what do you think happened there?
Her margin account just kept going up and up and up.
I mean,
it went up amazingly so you could conclude that she is a brilliant trader and
she ought to be president of the United States.
But then the next question is why did she stop or why did she run it for a
hundred fold increase in stop?
Anyone have any idea?
What is this common knowledge to this story?
Well,
the story ends there.
Nobody knows what happened.
Uh,
futures traders are willing to exercise a guess of what happened.
Anyone have any guests?
What,
what,
what do you think happened?
Well,
uh,
I shouldn't say things.
So political,
I do like Hillary,
what likely happened is some future's commission.
Merchant was thinking of bribing the governor.
Uh,
maybe he didn't,
you know,
I never actually did it,
but you know,
let's do a little favor for his wife and then maybe I can,
maybe I can ask him for something later.
And so the future is merchant just didn't listen carefully to what she said.
He just,
well,
he sort of cooked the books and gave her money by making it look like a trade.
Uh,
and when she found out what,
what finally likely happen is someone said,
do you think you're making so much money in the futures market?
Remember who your husband is and this guy,
do you trust him?
So she might add,
this is a likely guest.
She finally wondered what is going on here?
And she stopped because she didn't know what was happening either.
Somehow money was coming in.
And uh,
so that's the very,
and now maybe she was just very savvy and her investing ability,
but usually your futures accounts go both up and down and you get margin calls.
Uh,
so,
uh,
anyway,
the last day of the contract,
there was a settlement.
And,
and it,
well in agricultural futures,
the last day there was delivery.
If you're still in the contract,
if you are a seller on the last day,
you must deliver the specified number of barrels are bushes,
bushels of whatever it is.
Or if you are a buyer,
you must take delivery of them.
But with stock futures it's different because nobody expects you to deliver
shares of stock.
So what happens on the last day is there's a final settlement,
uh,
and that is in dollars in this case,
250 times the s and p 500 index at the,
on the last day,
minus the futures price,
uh,
of the preceding day.
And that's the settlement.
Uh,
of course you have been gaining the changes in the futures prices every
preceding the,
if you,
this is what you receive as a buyer.
If you bought the contract and this is what you pay if you sold the contract.
All right?
And so,
uh,
every day between the time you originally bought,
you've been getting,
if you were a buyer,
the change in the futures price and at the end you get this.
If you sum all those up,
all the settlements you got since you bought the contract until the expiration
of the contract,
you would be getting the index at time t minus the futures when you bought.
Okay.
And so that,
that defines it,
right?
Every day you get the change in the future price,
those all add up into your margin account.
And on the last day you get this.
So what does it really you're doing if you could say,
and they wouldn't like to say,
put it this way,
at the IX futures exchanges,
they don't like gambling analogies,
but I make ya gambling analogy analogy.
It's freely in this course.
It's like placing a bet on the,
on the stock market.
If you think the stock market is going to go up,
you buy the futures and if you think it's going to go down,
you sell the futures.
If you buy one contract,
how much money do you get?
You get in total over the toll interval between the purchase date and the
expiration of the contract.
You get the stock minus the initial futures price.
You paid times $250.
Okay.
And that's,
that's the gamble.
And if you sell,
it's just exactly the opposite.
So,
uh,
and so,
now
there's something called fair value and you'll see this talked about a lot in
futures.
This is what the future is.
Price should be okay.
Uh,
and we talked about it in terms of wheat.
Remember the fair value of a wheat futures was equal to the price of wheat today
times one plus the interest rate plus the storage costs.
That was the formula we had last time.
Right?
And that was the fair value because we concluded that somebody who is storing
grain has to make their expenses.
They have to make the interest cost and they have to make the storage costs.
So this,
the futures price should be equal to fair value.
It's the same here with stock index futures.
The fair value F of a futures contract is equal to the stock price.
Uh,
plus the stock price times the interest rate plus the storage cost and the
storage costs for stocks is negative because it doesn't cost you anything to
start a stock.
We don't even have to store certificates anymore though your name will be held
electronically.
It's negative because you get dividends.
Okay.
And so why is the dividend yield that you get on the stock?
So our minus why a is the adjustment you have to make,
but you see this to get from the stock price to fair value.
You see this as the same formula that we had for wheat except that you
understand that storage costs or stocks are negative because they pay a
dividend.
So all I've done is I've doubled the way I wrote it before.
It was p times one plus r plus s and the pre preceding lecture.
Now it's p times one plus r minus y because s equals minus y.
But that is,
that's the fair value,
uh,
of a,
of a stock index futures.
And,
uh,
hmm.
Now we said last time that sometimes prices deviate from fair value,
uh,
or maybe they don't,
depending on how you define fair value.
But if you define fair value as one plus r plus s where s is just the cost of a
warehouse,
then sometimes that formula doesn't work because,
uh,
we talked about last time at the end of the growing season,
nobody is storing wheat anymore.
Uh,
and so the,
the wheat market falls into backwardation in the futures price gets low.
Whoa,
okay.
Uh,
uh,
but,
other than that,
so normally we just being stored.
And so normally wheat prices,
uh,
are essentially equal to fair value,
but stocks are always being stored.
So there's,
there's no,
uh,
it would be unusual to see backwardation in this market would be abnormal
because we're always storing stars.
That's what we do with them is we hold them dividend yield.
Uh,
uh,
you can have backwardation.
However,
if the dividend yield is greater than the interest rate because then the
adjustment would make the futures price below the cash price.
All right.
Otherwise you can't have backwardation in this market.
So price should always equal fair value.
Uh,
uh,
so,
um,
right now we're in an unusual circumstance where the interest rate and the
dividend yield or about the same,
right now the Fed has cut short term interest rates,
the federal funds rate to two and a quarter percent.
That's very close to the dividend yield on the s and p 500.
So at this point of time the futures price is very close to the spot price and
so we fair value of calculations are relatively unimportant.
Alright,
are there any questions you understand this?
I have a a clipping from,
I took it from yesterday's Wall Street Journal.
Uh,
and this is to prove that the Wall Street Journal is still publishing financial
data even though they've cut way back.
Uh,
this used to be a longer interview,
but this is what they have a as of yesterday.
So,
uh,
now this says the standard and poor 500.
This is under a future's prices,
Chicago Mercantile Exchange,
and they're reminding you that the settlement is 250 times the index,
and they show two contracts,
one expiring in June and one expiring in December.
Okay.
And these are the prices.
This is the opening price.
Uh,
at the beginning of the day,
this is the highest price for the day that the contracts traded.
And this is the lowest price or traded at the day.
And this is the settled price,
which is essentially the last price of the day.
Uh,
okay.
And this is the change in the settle from the preceding day.
Uh,
and this is the open interest.
It's 550,000 contract.
Do you understand what all this means?
Uh,
so if you,
uh,
now interesting.
It looks like there's backwardation because the December futures at open is
lower than the June futures,
but I,
I think this must be,
it's not much lower.
I think,
um,
it may have something to do with timing of the trades,
but if you look at the settled price over here,
they are almost exactly identical between June and December.
Uh,
and that there is,
it's not backwardation,
it's contango the futures price is above the,
uh,
it's going up as the horizon.
It goes out.
So,
uh,
that,
that's where we are today.
And they're talking an awful lot about futures,
stock index futures.
Uh,
and so if you,
if you watch CNBC,
they're always talking about it.
Uh,
and,
uh,
the reason is,
is that it's such a big and liquid market.
In fact,
the futures market,
s and p futures market,
as I said,
it's gotten bigger than the,
than the stock market itself,
at least at certain times.
Uh,
it's also just a more trustworthy number,
uh,
and it's,
it moves faster.
So it's,
it's gotten very,
um,
uh,
a great deal of attention.
Why does the futures market moves so fast and why is it such a popular
instrument?
Uh,
I think that the main reason is that it is a market that,
um,
it's like a wholesale market for antiques rather than the local antique dealer.
Okay.
So if you went to an antique dealer in new haven to try to buy some furniture
for your apartment,
uh,
who knows what price you'd get,
right?
It would be very erratic.
Uh,
and you'd be dealing with one on one with a dealer.
Well,
that's what happens in the future.
It's in the,
in the stock market as well.
Uh,
so,
uh,
remember I was telling you that a dealer has to have a bid ask spread of an
antique dealer.
They,
they,
they'll buy the chest of drawers at a lower price,
then they'll sell it.
And the difference between bid and ask is there bid ask spread.
And that's their profit.
Uh,
dealers have to keep a wide bid aspirin because they have a lot of expenses and
they have the risk of,
of being ripped off by more knowledgeable people who really know antiques and
will buy their best stuff and leave behind the junk.
And because they're constantly exposed to this risk,
antique dealers keep wide bid,
ask spreads.
Uh,
so it's the same with the stock market.
The people,
this specialist or the,
uh,
dealers who trade on the stock market with customers have the same concerns.
So they keep relatively wide bid ask spreads.
But in the futures market there is,
it's cleaner,
there's a huge volume of trade,
it's very competitive and there's less fear about being ripped off by someone
who has special knowledge because who knows what this index is going to do
anyway.
So dealers have narrow bid ask spreads in the futures market.
Alright.
And,
and as a result,
the futures market is where the action is.
Uh,
and so the people who doubted that back in 1980,
who doubted that financial futures would ever take off.
We're really wrong.
Even though stocks are perfectly standardized,
every share is the same as every other.
Share the,
uh,
we do need a futures market.
Uh,
and so the future's market,
uh,
is,
is very important.
Uh,
anyway,
I wanted to talk about,
or is there any questions about oil,
about stock futures?
I went through it kind of quickly,
but it is a,
um,
the important thing though is just to understand fair value.
It's actually a very simple market to understand.
Once you know this formula,
you pretty much know the price for any future date.
Remember the r again as in the preceding lecture is not the annual interest rate
unless we're talking about a contract that matures in one year.
Uh,
it's the interest between now and expiration date.
Okay.
Uh,
and the same thing with dividends.
This is the dividend yield where we're not talking about annual dividend yield,
but the dividends as a fraction of the price between now and maturity of the
contract.
And so that's the only formula that we really need.
Uh,
so let's think of it.
The stock index futures market is where you really look to see where the stock
market is moving.
It's faster than the stock price index itself that the SNP publishes.
The S and p 500 is a little bit behind the thing that's trading on.
And why is that?
Well,
it's because some of the stocks in the s and p 500 index don't trade really
minute by minute with the same speed that you think.
Uh,
and,
uh,
and so the s and p 500 is always catching up on itself,
the actual index.
But this market has all the smartest traders trading it,
and they kind of know when the s and p 500 is lagging.
And so they,
they immediately corrected in the futures price.
So the future is priced is the place to look for what the stock market is really
doing.
Um,
or I'll move to oil future,
which is a matter of great interest right now because of the turmoil and the oil
market.
Uh,
and oil futures actually go back,
uh,
they're not so old either.
Uh,
compared to wheat or corn they developed in the early 1980s.
Um,
do I have,
yeah.
Uh,
so,
okay.
This is the Nymex oil futures market.
Uh,
and,
um,
there are many futures markets for oil,
but the Nymex is the most important one.
And they are,
this is different.
It's a physical delivery,
oil futures market,
no different from the agricultural futures.
So,
uh,
they define a particular grade of oil and,
they call it light sweet crude oil.
Sweet oil is better than sour oil.
Uh,
I wouldn't try tasting it,
but,
uh,
the refiners like it better.
Uh,
generally.
and so it's a grade of oil or it's also called West Texas intermediate.
Uh,
and you have to,
if you,
if you buy a contract and you hold it to maturity,
you are going to have to take delivery of 1000 barrels of light sweet crude oil
in Cushing,
Oklahoma,
and they picked Cushing.
Oklahoma is kind of central to the country,
so you could call your broker and buy a contract today.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
you could get the May contract.
Uh,
and then in May you'd have to take a trip down to Cushing and get your 1000
barrels a,
or you could sell in the futures market.
Uh,
and that would mean that you would have,
you would be promising to deliver 1000 barrels.
As I said last time,
almost nobody who trades these contracts actually takes delivery or makes,
uh,
delivery,
because almost everyone closes out their contract before that.
Uh,
but,
um,
so,
uh,
but it's the same idea as all the other oil contracts.
Uh,
so you,
uh,
you have contracts maturing and each month is one.
We're already,
we've already passed the expiration of the April contract.
Uh,
so it's made June,
July,
August,
etc. Uh,
and uh,
this is the price there.
These are,
uh,
well actually the,
they make a distinction between last and settle.
The settled prices,
the important price,
because that determines the changes in your margin account.
So the,
uh,
settled price,
as,
uh,
yesterday reached $113 and 44 cents per barrel,
which is a record high.
Uh,
uh,
and you can see that as delivery dates go out,
the uh,
settled price goes down.
So the oil market is currently in backwardation.
All right?
Now remember what we said about futures is that normally they're in contango.
Remember the futures price fair value tends to equal the price today times one,
plus the interest plus storage costs.
Okay.
Storage costs for oil are substantial.
This is a thick,
bulky commodity.
You've got to have one of those storage tanks.
You see them out there and new haven harbor,
they cost money.
Uh,
it's expensive to store.
So storage costs are not negligible for oil.
Plus interest rates are positive.
So we would think that oil should have contango.
Normally it should price,
it should be going up,
but very frequently oil is not in contango and right now it is not.
You can see that oil prices are lower by October according to the futures
market.
Uh,
and so I wanted to reflect a little bit on what oil,
uh,
what,
what is going on in the oil market.
Um,
and the thing you have to understand in terms of what you understand the
contract,
it's exactly the same as a week contract.
It's just a contract to deliver a thousand barrels or receive it.
And if you do that,
you don't have to come up with oil today.
You've probably never come up with her.
You'd have to come up with margin today and your margin account will reflect the
change in oil prices.
This is the number you see in the newspaper.
This is when they talk about the price of oil in the newspaper.
This is it.
Uh,
there's also something called Platts,
which is a company that,
uh,
I guess it's a Mcgraw Hill company that,
that does cash prices of oil,
but,
uh,
it's,
it's not coded as much because I don't think it's as reliable as this.
Uh,
the problem with,
uh,
with,
you might say this is a month in the future,
uh,
isn't that it,
that's not today's price,
but that's what people are coding as today's price because it's the most
accurate price.
Uh,
and so now why is it going into backwardation?
so I wanted to think about storage of oil because we were saying that everything
should be generally in contango.
Um,
isn't,
aren't they storing oil?
As I said,
if you drive out to new haven harbor,
you see all these storage tanks and don't they have oil?
And,
um,
uh,
and so I wanted to think a little bit about where the oil is.
Most of the oil is still on the ground,
uh,
in,
you know,
in the Persian Gulf and Mexico and Russia and places.
But we don't count that as storage of oil because it has to be extracted and
it's not just there for a sale.
There's a,
there's a lag.
So we have to consider oil that's above ground and ready to go.
Uh,
and so it is stored and it's stored here in new haven.
in fact,
the government of the United States has created what they call a strategic
petroleum reserve and it has taken oil and it's storing it in caverns,
in caves.
And this is in case of a national emergency where we've suddenly really need
oil.
Uh,
but that isn't going to affect this market because it's being held by the
government for some war or some terrible event and it's not on the market.
So that doesn't affect,
uh,
the,
even though the market is in backwardation and the government is not going to
sell off this oil,
uh,
so it's not affecting the market.
The other thing that's happened is there's a heating oil reserve and this was
created by President Clinton,
uh,
in,
in the year 2000.
And that is actually in two places.
It's in New York.
And New Haven.
So we,
we are the storage place for heating oil.
Uh,
and this is not a strategic petroleum reserve,
but it's the reserve that the government can use to stabilize the heating oil
market.
They were concerned about spikes and heating oil affecting people who are in
difficult economic circumstances.
So that reserve,
uh,
could,
could ultimately affect the market if the government chooses to sell it off.
Uh,
but they only have 2 million barrels,
so it's not big.
I think the first thing to recognize about the oil market is that there isn't
much storage compared to the,
uh,
flow through basically what we have in oil.
As we have those wells all over the world pumping oil,
they put it into tankers,
the tankers take it across the ocean to various countries where it goes into
temporary storage at harbors,
but it doesn't stay there long.
It keeps flowing through and then it puts,
put on oil trucks and it's driven.
It's different.
The refinery,
he's,
and then,
uh,
and it ends up in the gas stations.
Uh,
so,
uh,
there's not a lot of oil in storage.
And so that's why the oil market is very often in backwardation because the
price of oil reflects the temporary scarcities of oil.
Uh,
and if there's any shortage of oil,
if something happens,
then,
uh,
the oil price can jump up.
Uh,
and everybody knows it's going to come back down.
And so it,
so you can have backwardation basically you don't have,
uh,
people selling off their stores when there's a backwardation like we talked
about last time,
it's not like at the end of the harvest,
people know when the wheat harvest is coming and people know that wheat prices
should go down and they sell off the stores.
It's not like that.
Here are the stories that we have of oil are,
have a convenience yield.
Uh,
and so there it's something that doesn't backwardation doesn't quickly correct
itself.
So I think that what this means here is backwardation in the oil market is that
people think that oils have spiked up,
there's a temporary shortage and that prices are going to come down somewhat,
although not a whole lot here.
Um,
uh,
this is,
a futures term structure.
I haven't plotted for a number of years.
Uh,
and I should have made this a little bigger.
It's a little hard to read,
but this is today.
Uh,
so what this is,
is for all of these are from today's news all on this top line.
And what it shows is for every maturity out to six years what the futures price
is.
So right now we're at $114 a barrel.
Uh,
but the market is predicting a decline,
not a whole huge decline that back to something like $108 a barrel in six years.
Uh,
and uh,
you can see that,
uh,
um,
the futures market has often been predicting either increases or declines and
you can look at different times in history.
A particular interest here I have Hurricane Katrina,
uh,
and uh,
I can't,
uh,
right,
this is December.
This is Hurricane Katrina.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
right after the hurricane,
in,
um,
uh,
August of 2005,
the hurricane destroyed some of our refining capability and some of our storage
tanks could because New Orleans is a oil center were tankers come and they go,
they go up the Mississippi River.
Uh,
and so we destroyed the hurricane,
destroyed a part of our infrastructure.
So everybody in the market knew that that means that oil prices are temporarily
high.
And so you can see the,
the backwardation in the market,
but we see even more backwardation right today.
So that,
that's,
that's an indication that there's something going on in the short run in our
market.
If you believe the market,
uh,
what do I have?
I have here,
this goes way back.
This one is 1990 and he knows it stops after 18 months.
That's because in 1990,
the futures market wasn't as developed as it is.
Not only went out 18 months,
but you can see there was strong backwardation.
Uh,
this was when Saddam Hussein invaded Kuwait.
and,
uh,
it caused tremendous disruption of oil supply and everybody knew that's
temporary.
And so the future's price were lower.
That was about the most backward dated futures market we've seen in oil.
Oh,
today it's pretty backwardated so,
but not so not as dramatically percentage wise.
It was after Katrina.
Um,
this is a plot of,
uh,
oil prices,
in the United States.
This is West Texas intermediate.
Uh,
well actually I'm not sure it's all the way back.
Is West Texas?
No,
it's not all the way back with cause Texas oil wasn't discovered until around
1900,
I think.
I'm not sure about that date exactly.
This is Pennsylvania oil back here.
I've got it going way back.
Uh,
but the interesting thing about this,
this is of interest at the moment.
The oil prices now are higher than they've ever been.
And this is in real terms,
a real inflation correct in terms.
Uh,
so very interesting what this means for our lives.
just 10 years ago,
oil was at a record low,
uh,
that,
we were,
uh,
like a little over $10 a barrel.
So what is going on here?
We've seen the oil price jump up something,
uh,
close to 10 fold in 10 years.
Uh,
it's a huge surprise.
so,
uh,
but there are other support.
One thing I wanted to do was to go through,
uh,
just a few,
um,
uh,
see where am I going to go here?
Uh,
go through a few stories about oil prices here.
I,
this was a period when oil was stable,
generally very stable.
Uh,
in the post World War II period.
there was a Texas railroad commission that was stabilizing oil prices.
At that time.
The US was not a big importer of oil.
We had our own oil supply.
And,
uh,
we,
we tended to,
uh,
we,
we had a sort of a monopoly that tried to stabilize the price and they were
pretty successful for this long time period.
The huge shock came,
and this is called the first oil shock.
And that was in 1973 74,
uh,
oils,
oil went up.
It went up more than doubled,
right?
That's like almost three times increase in oil price all of a sudden.
Uh,
and that was associated with,
uh,
with the particular,
it's called the first oil crisis.
Uh,
and it coincides with the Yom Kippur war between Israel and her Arab neighbors.
and it caused the,
uh,
Israel quickly triumphed in that war,
but it left a lot of bad feelings among the surrounding Arab Arab countries who
were sympathetic with the Palestinian cars.
And so they cut back on their oil production.
We have,
um,
a,
uh,
an organization called OPEC.
Uh,
so,
uh,
this is,
you can see this oh pack,
that's the Organization of Petroleum Exporting Countries and it was established
in 1960
with a small number of Arab countries,
but they've grout gradually grown and has more and more,
uh,
more and more,
countries that are members.
So it was oh pack that construct constrained the supply of oil for the first oil
crisis.
This is the second oil crisis here.
And that was,
um,
in,
1979 80.
And this again,
had its origin,
at least the common story.
And it must be some truth to this story.
It had its origin in another crisis in the Middle East.
Uh,
and that was the war between Iraq and Iran.
and so,
uh,
there was a Iranian revolution in 1979 where the Shah of Iran was thrown out and
the Ayatollah Khomeini came in Iraq.
Use this as an opportunity to try to grab some oil from Iran.
This war completely disrupted oil supplies and we had this huge spike in oil
prices then,
uh,
and,
a lot of these spikes seem to have political causes.
This spike in the oil price is caused by the 1991.
A invasion of the,
uh,
the United States was the primary inventor of Iraq.
This was after September 11th.
Uh,
and this,
uh,
disruptive oil supplies,
again,
all of these times were periods of backwardation in the oil market because
people saw them as crises that was limiting the supply of oil for now,
but would eventually correct itself.
Um,
uh,
so,
yeah,
so what's happening now?
This is just an amazing spike of oil right now.
There isn't,
I mean,
we have this war in Iraq,
but it's not sudden intense thing that,
uh,
it's not disrupting oil supplies.
Uh,
so why are we seeing this huge spike in oil?
And that is an interesting question.
Part of it has to do with the fact that we have a rapidly growing world economy
and developing countries are moving forward faster than was anticipated.
So there's a lot of demand for oil from India,
China and other rapidly developing countries.
Um,
so they say that,
uh,
China,
builds a new city the size of Houston,
Texas every month.
And so,
uh,
they are consuming an awful lot of energy to do this.
Um,
the other side of it is,
uh,
discoveries of oil have been disappointing.
So I was just down in Mexico,
uh,
and the President Calderon is talking about privatizing the Mexican oil or this
part of it,
uh,
oil industry because have been disappointing,
in their exploration I had,
they're not finding oil.
So the reserves that Mexico has has been actually declining rapidly.
Um,
and uh,
oh,
this brings up another thing about the ownership of all hell.
I just wanted to mention,
uh,
nationalization.
Uh,
it used to be that,
uh,
most of the oil in the world was owned by private companies or individuals,
but a nationalization began in 1938 in Mexico where a left leaning government
defined.
It decided that all the oil,
uh,
Mexican oil that was owned by foreigners really belonged to the Mexican people.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
the Mexican government just said it's hours.
That was an outrageous thing to say then.
But,
uh,
it was greeted by shock about international law.
Uh,
they just took the oil in their country saying that it wasn't fair that way.
It was so,
uh,
it was followed up by in 1951 by Iran and other countries followed as well.
Uh,
but now we're seeing a reverse.
So it,
Mexico nationalize its oil in 1938,
but now that the supply is dwindling,
the president called her own,
wants to reverse the process.
This is controversial now,
uh,
in,
in yesterday's newspaper.
And if you read the Wall Street Journal,
it had a story saying that,
uh,
Russian for the first quarter of 2008 Russian production of oil declined for the
first time in 10 years.
And there's worry now that Russia is running out of oil.
So I think it's these,
uh,
this,
impact of,
of news like this is having a psychological effect on the market and it's
causing a huge robot.
You might consider it as a bubble in oil prices,
uh,
but I'm not so sure that it's available.
Uh,
it's,
uh,
it's certainly unprecedented.
It seems like we're entering a period of great market volatility.
We've seen an unprecedented bubble in home prices and now the economy is reeling
from this,
from the effects of this bubble.
But look what's happening as well in oil prices.
And once again,
there's no war right now.
There's nothing really dramatic how well we do have,
you know,
you make,
you could call it a war,
but it's not something that has shut down the Persian Gulf,
uh,
and closed off oil supplies.
So it seems like it's something,
uh,
something more,
um,
uh,
systemic.
It's something more to do with the economic situation then before or it's
something speculative.
Uh,
and um,
we have,
so we,
we have backwardation but it's not a whole lot of backwardation.
They're still predicting oil prices to come down to something like,
they're like,
well over a hundred in eight years.
So it's not,
uh,
it's not a,
um,
it's not something that's related to a particular crisis that,
uh,
that is going to end quickly.
Uh,
so I wanted to go,
I,
uh,
this is,
this just as a clipping I got from,
uh,
this is the day that,
Saddam Hussein announced an oil embargo.
Uh,
this was in his reaction to the United States,
um,
uh,
pressure on him.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
oil prices spiked up.
It seems dramatic.
When I made this clipping.
Now oil is $100 a barrel.
You know,
that's just only,
that's only what,
six years ago.
But at that time,
people thought the market thought that oil prices were coming back down by oh
three,
they were really wrong.
If people didn't get it all this time,
people thought that oil,
they,
you know,
a large part of the time it was in backwardation,
they thought that there's some special event occurring.
This is Saddam Hussein.
Uh,
but it turns out that there was something driving it up.
This is again,
oh,
this is natural gas on that same date.
This is still in contango because the prices are going up to time.
So that kind of explains that if Saddam Hussein was selectively hitting on the
oil market and not the natural gas market explains those two markets.
I want to talk briefly about other futures.
There's a gold futures market,
uh,
and the gold futures market.
Uh,
this is a clip and old clipping I had of it.
It's a very steady contango market.
That's because gold is very different from oil.
Gold is in storage.
Uh,
there's nothing to do with gold.
I said,
hold it.
You don't burn it.
That's a different oil.
You burn it and it's gone.
So we don't have much around and we're,
we're always vulnerable to some supply interruption.
That was gold.
There's no supply and we don't burn gold.
It just sits there and we're holding this stuff.
We don't know what to do with that.
It can't really be in contango for very long because someone who's holding gold
is going to say,
hey,
if it's going down in the futures market,
I'm not going to sit on this stuff.
I'm going to sell it.
So it,
it stays in a dress.
I can tango efforts in backwardation people would sell it.
So it stays very nicely in contango and it's going up at the rate of interest,
the storage.
But there's a storage costs as well.
But I don't know how big that is for gold.
I guess you'd have to pay for police force to defend your gold,
something like that.
So it must have some storage costs.
But,
uh,
it's a very simple market,
because it,
uh,
it stays in contango all the time.
Copper futures.
Now copper is different from gold because,
uh,
it's not,
this is a,
this is a 2004 clipping.
Again,
copper is an industrial commodity that gets used up.
And so it suffers from supply disruptions.
And it can,
uh,
like oil,
it can fall into backwardation.
So here,
uh,
I should,
I should write these.
Did I ever write these down?
And Tango,
it's just doesn't make sure his wins,
futures prices are going up as the maturity with maturity,
higher prices for more future dates.
Backwardation is when it's going down.
Okay.
So,
uh,
this is an example of a backward backwardated market.
The prices as we go out to further and further,
this is 2004 when we go out to December of that year,
it's down from 139 to 136.
And when we go out to,
uh,
December of the following year,
it's down to 118.
Uh,
goal by the way,
has gone up a lot too.
There's been a lot of commodity price increases that surprises this is the
federal funds future.
Another clipping,
there's a futures market for the federal funds rate,
uh,
and it's a cash settled,
because you can't deliver a federal funds.
The settlement,
uh,
the,
the price shown,
uh,
is a hundred minus the federal funds rate.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
back then in a,
this is 2004,
the federal funds rate was about 5%.
So this is a,
looks like five and a quarter percent.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
100 minus 94.74 is five and a quarter percent.
That's what the federal funds rate was expected to be,
uh,
in March of 2004.
Uh,
and here you see that the federal funds rate was expected to continue to decline
at that time.
Um,
this market can go either way because you don't store a federal funds,
so there's no fair value calculation like there are with the other markets.
So,
uh,
it reflects expectations of future interest rates.
Um,
right now I don't,
I should have gotten today's,
but I think the federal funds futures market is predicting right now with the
federal funds rate at two and a quarter percent,
the federal funds market,
this would be 97.75.
Now a hundred minus two and a quarter or be close to that and it would be going
down with time.
People are expecting the Fed to cut interest rates and sorry,
growing these numbers would be going up.
Uh,
but I don't have the flipping for today.
I just finally wanted to talk about a home price futures,
which is a,
and a market that I've gotten involved with creating a at the Chicago Mercantile
Exchange.
Uh,
so I got involved with them because I have a price index.
My colleague and I,
Carl Case,
who's a professor at Wellesley College,
um,
he and I in the late 1980s created a home price index.
Uh,
this was our research and put it out as a working paper here at Yale,
uh,
20 years ago.
Uh,
and,
uh,
but from the beginning we thought that the real importance of having a home
price index is for trading.
We live in a world where people don't trade.
Uh,
there's no international market for real estate.
and it's quite remarkable that there is not,
because real estate is a huge
asset class.
Uh,
the value of single family homes in this country is about 30% bigger than the
value of the stock market in the u s um,
yet we see so much talk about the stock market.
Uh,
when we started in 1988,
we realized not only was there no market for a single family homes except the
very,
the very local market.
Um,
there was also no price index for single family homes.
Uh,
Eh,
you know,
it's just sometimes amazing how undeveloped things are.
Here we are in the 20th century.
Everything is computerized and all that,
but you just want,
I just want to know what home prices have been doing in the United States,
uh,
in the late 1980s.
And you couldn't find out where there were some indexes,
but they were rather poor.
Uh,
we thought.
And so,
uh,
and uh,
not very reliable.
So we did our econometric work,
uh,
and devise a method of a repeat sales method of home price indexes.
Uh,
I wrote a book in 1993 about,
uh,
called macro markets about,
um,
it talked a lot about index number construction.
And I said in the book that we need to devise a home price index,
that it's as close as possible to something like the s and p 500,
which is a stock price index.
But the problem with home prices is we have a much bigger non trading problem.
Uh,
uh,
the s and p 500 is not very out of date because docs usually don't go untreated
for more than a few minutes or maybe a few hours at times.
But with homes,
the typical home doesn't trade every 10 years.
And so we have a huge non trading problem.
Then what we did is we created an index that was as close as possible to a stock
price index so that it could be traded on a,
on a financial market.
And then I had a student here,
uh,
Alan Weiss who said,
why don't we get going and get,
my student was graduate,
he actually was an som student Mba student.
Uh,
and he said,
uh,
he was,
he was graduating and he thought we should produce these indexes for sale,
for use in financial markets.
Uh,
and so he wanted to do it.
And he set up our company case Shiller Weiss Incorporated,
and he ran it.
And,
and Casey and I were just on the advisory where we were on the board of
directors,
but we were just advising operation.
So my,
I was so proud of him for my student,
created the case Shiller home price indexes.
Uh,
and we started publishing them.
Um,
and then in 19,
early 1990s,
we traveled to all the futures markets and it's proposing to them that they
create home price futures based on our indexes.
Um,
and,
uh,
it was a disappointing,
we couldn't get anyone to do it.
Uh,
I thought we had such a strong case.
It shouldn't,
shouldn't there be a market futures market?
I,
we,
we went to the,
uh,
I mentioned the coffee sugar coco works and we tried them.
All right.
So we go to these guys and they're trading coffee and sugar and cocoa.
And I said,
look,
you know,
coffee is nice.
I mean,
everyone wants their cup in the morning,
but we're talking about $20 trillion of unhedged risk.
Most households in the United States,
that's what they all in a typical household.
They don't own much stock,
they own real estate and they can't hedge it.
So we,
we,
uh,
I think we had the most progress with the Chicago Board of trade.
They actually did some research with us.
Uh,
the funny thing that happened that Cvot did research in 1994 and whether they
should set up a futures market for single family homes and the basic conclusion,
they made a lot of phone calls.
It's how they did research,
asking people,
are you worried about your home price falling and would you like to be able to
hedge the risk in the futures market the way farmers do in the agricultural
market?
And basically the answer was no.
And people,
uh,
said,
I don't worry about my home price falling.
Uh,
and so they didn't want to start a market cause they thought,
but was going around saying,
don't you know,
there's no love economic saying home prices don't fall.
They did.
They have fallen,
they fought,
they fell a lot in the depression.
Uh,
and they could do it again.
And so a lot of people want to,
you know,
have a market that they don't just go steadily up.
Uh,
but people said,
well,
the depression,
that was so long ago,
we can't remember that.
Uh,
and so we couldn't seem to get anyone focused on it.
I think there's something about this that we learned about the origins of our
current economic situation.
Uh,
so we went around to a lot of people trying to get them interested in hedging
real estate price.
Remember,
the purpose of future's market is not gambling,
it's hedging.
It's protecting yourself.
I should write that term on the board as well.
Hedging.
Okay.
I hope I made this clear.
If you are running,
let's go back to wheat.
If you have a warehouse full of wheat,
okay?
You are a wheat Weyerhaeuser and you were like a stable business.
So what do you do?
Uh,
you don't know what the price of wheat is going to do.
It goes up and down internationally.
So what do you do?
You sell it in the futures market,
and that means you've hedged your risk of wheat prices.
If wheat prices go down,
true,
the value of the stuff in storage that you own is going to go down.
But offsetting that is your futures contract price will go up.
And that,
that,
that hedging we'll protect you.
And so you have reduced risk of your business.
And this is done a lot.
Holbrook working in the reading talks about that.
So farmers also can head,
they've got wheat growing in the fields,
uh,
and they're worried about the price they can sell it at.
So let's lock it in today.
Let's sell in the futures market.
Uh,
and the,
the,
uh,
if the price of wheat declines,
your short position in the futures market will appreciate and offset your loss.
So you want to hedge your risk.
So we went around asking people,
don't you want to hedge your risks in the real estate market?
Uh,
and,
uh,
unfortunately people are rather confused about that and they're not used to
hedging that.
Uh,
but anyway,
uh,
with the recent boom in home prices,
we were able,
we finally approached the Chicago Mercantile Exchange in 2006,
uh,
and,
so we want to work with you to create,
try to create a futures market for single family homes.
Uh,
and they said,
okay,
let's try it.
And so this was a,
what we did in May of 2006,
we created a futures market.
Uh,
the,
uh,
not the very first,
there was an attempt in London in 1991 that failed,
but we were essentially the first of our futures market for single family homes
in the United States.
Uh,
and,
um,
this market,
uh,
has been in backwardation almost from the first day when we opened the market in
May of 2006 are market maker,
uh,
who was brought in by the Chicago Mercantile Exchange thought like everyone else
who reads the newspapers.
Well,
home prices just always go up.
And so they,
the,
the market maker,
uh,
put out a bid,
ask that implied contango in the market that home prices would go up.
But the,
uh,
the market maker quickly learned that there was no market contango market.
Uh,
and he,
after losing a huge amount of money,
he pushed his bid,
ask spreads into the backwardation range and left it there ever since.
And so this is,
this shows the backwardation in the futures market,
uh,
recently,
but it's been this way for a couple of years now.
So what's going on in the housing market?
I think that what has been happening is that newspapers and real estate agents
and lots of commentators,
uh,
people you see on the news have been telling us that home prices always go up.
They've never fallen.
Uh,
and uh,
don't worry.
Okay.
So a lot of casual people have believed that,
but the kind of people who trade in futures markets didn't believe it.
Even going back to early 2006 people who are ready to put their money on the
line had been predicting a decline in home prices now for two years.
And you can see what dramatic declines are being predicted in our futures
market.
Uh,
so I have it for various cities.
Boston,
Chicago,
Denver,
all,
we have separate markets for each of the 10 of these 10 cities.
Las Vegas,
Los Angeles,
Miami,
New York,
San Diego,
and San Francisco.
So I'm the worst market of the mall is Miami.
Uh,
and this market is predicting almost a 35% home price decline,
uh,
by November of 2012.
Um,
and the second worst,
what is the second worst?
I can't quite read it.
They kind of merged here.
There's a bunch of cities where the prediction is for a 20 to 25% drop.
Uh,
and the best,
the best city of all is Chicago.
But even there,
there are predicting a 7% drop.
So we've seen a lot of backwardation in that market.
Uh,
I think this is reflecting the,
the unusual economic circumstance where im fine.
This is my last slide.
This shows the,
uh,
the,
the s and p case,
Shiller home price index.
Uh,
that line is the actual home price index.
And it has these jumps in it every month because it's a monthly index if we only
publish it every month.
But you can see that it's been very smooth.
It was increasing until around the time we started the futures market.
Uh,
and then it's been declining at an accelerating rate.
So we are now down in real terms about 15% a nationwide,
uh,
on home prices,
which peaked in early 2006.
This is the futures price that we've had and that's for the closest futures
contract,
the nearest to expiration.
And so,
uh,
we're,
we're hoping to get a lot of publicity for this cause we thought this was a very
interesting number.
This is a futures market price for homes and it moves around day by day.
You all those little wiggles reflect new information that came in on,
on a particular day.
Uh,
unfortunately we have not been able to get much attention for this number.
but there's been a lot of attention to our are the s and p case Shiller home
price index is now,
uh,
in fact,
we're getting,
uh,
newspaper stories all the time written about our indexes,
but they don't write about our market.
Uh,
and so we've had trouble getting a futures market started.
it's going,
but it's going only at a low level.
But I think that in the future this will take off eventually.
I,
I think that we'll have futures markets for many more things.
Uh,
but eventually we'll have a futures market for new haven as well.
Right now new haven is too small to warrant its own futures market.
So I was thinking of,
well someone in new haven could just buy two,
or if you wanted to hedge your house,
you'd sell to New York contracts and one Boston conjugation verb interpolated
between New New York and Boston.
But eventually we have to do better than that.
Uh,
and I,
I'm hopeful that there will be a day in my lifetime we will see all cities of
the world traded on futures market.
And in my new book,
sub prime solution,
I also complaint,
I also claim,
I think I have some faith in basis to say this,
that it will help reduce bubbles and help reduce the kind of instability.
Next period we're going to talk about options.
Uh,
and then we have only one more lecture.
The last lecture on the democratization of finance.